[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
clémentine autain bonjour mon cher ça
vaut le coup d'être avec nous députés la
france insoumise et la seine saint denis
en détention pendant 20 minutes pour
l'interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par christelle bertrand bonjour cristal
devant jury
la dépêche on commence avec ce qui s'est
passé hier à béthune et cette réunion
entre ministres syndicats direction et
élus pour tenter de sauver les 8 163
emplois de l'usiné bridgestone est ce
que vous dites que le gouvernement fait
ce qu'il faut sur ce dossier le problème
du gouvernement c'est qu'il a accéléré
une politique qui tourne le dos à la
préservation de l'emploi
c'est ça le problème de fond donc c'est
un peu les pompiers pyromanes c'est à
dire qu'après il arrive sur les sites
ont des larmes de crocodile pour
expliquer que c'est une catastrophe
il y à des délocalisations et des
entreprises qui font des profits et qui
bénéficie dette publique parce que c'est
ça qui est particulièrement scandaleux
dans ce cas là comme dans beaucoup
d'autres cas c'est que la manne du cic
eux les et l'impôt crédits recherchent
si vous voulez les entreprises ont bien
engranger et pour autant cela ne les
empêche absolument pas de fermer des
usines comme bridgestone 7 7 qui avait
sa seule entreprise française de pneus à
béthune que ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
pour éviter
il faut changer radicalement nos
politiques publiques
ces salles pour le sait qu'il faut qu'on
sorte de cette logique on pense que la
compétitivité c'est le sésame que fait
le gouvernement
et à partir de cette compétitivité on
donne aux entreprises des milliards sans
aucune contrepartie en matière à la fois
de préservation de l'emploi c'est-à-dire
de d'enjeux sociaux importants et qui
touche aussi des territoires parce que
vous voyez bien béthune il ya ces
familles qui sont elles mêmes jeter dans
la précarité et potentiellement dans la
pauvreté
mais vous voyez bien que sur des
territoires comme béthune cetc enchaîne
ça veut dire et un endroit j'ai regardé
sur la menace et l'entreprise voilà et
aussi des contreparties en matière
environnementale ce sont à mon avis les
deux clés si on veut agir sur l'économie
et pas simplement être des spectateurs
et ensuite revenir parce qu'aujourd'hui
quel est le choix c'est encore de mettre
de l'argent
oui pour essayer de sauver des emplois
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait face à des
entreprises privées comme bridgestone
vous savez qu'en france comme dans
d'autres pays il existe des
réglementations et ça s'appelle la loi
voilà on vit en république il ya la loi
donc la loi elle doit organiser la vie
sociale et donc certes il y a en france
et dans l'économie que nous connaissons
de la propriété privée des intérêts
privés
mais ils n'ont pas tous pouvoir et ils
ne doivent pas avoir tout pouvoir sur
des entreprises et par ailleurs je pense
que le pouvoir des salariés dans
l'entreprise est un enjeu majeur pour
une nouvelle république
parce que qui décide de jouer comme ça
avec les entreprises on ferme ici on
ouvre ailleurs on profite du confinement
pour certaines entreprises et de la
crise du coc vide pour quelque part
accélérer des plans sociaux c'est ce qui
se passe et quand vous voyez la liste de
toutes les entreprises qui ont touché
des milliards des millions parfois de
vous appeler les salariés à reprendre le
pouvoir dans les entreprises les
organisations syndicales mais c'est pas
que je les appelle c'est j'appelle
l'état à organiser les choses
différemment de telle sorte que les
salariés aient dû pleuvoir dans
l'entreprise et de telle sorte que les
aides publiques
c'est ce qu'on arrête de donner tant
d'argent à des entreprises qui
licencient alors qu'il forme de co j'ai
bien tacler les en plus après on a des
ans et après c'est une catastrophe
regardez aujourd'hui sanofi sanofi qui
pourtant en 2018 a fait les profits
assez faramineux et qui probablement
dans la période que nous traversons peut
continuer à espérer gagner de l'argent
bas vous croyez que ça les arêtes non on
y va plans sociaux
donc là sur des comparaisons sur des
secteurs comme le médicament où
normalement il devrait y avoir une
maîtrise publique
bon vous d'accord avec la proposition de
laurent berger qui dit il faut que
maintenant l'argent qui va venir via le
plan de relance soit aussi co gérée par
les salariés par les élus du personnel
y'a un truc qui est un droit de regard
sur la manière dont était bien sûr il
faut un droit de regard sur sur l'argent
public qui arrive mais il faut un droit
de regard aussi sûr on ferme on ferme
pas vous rendez compte que pendant la
crise du covin on s'est rendu compte que
peut-être qu'on allait avoir une pénurie
de doliprane en france parce que cette
logique de délocalisation et de jeu en
fait hein vous avez vous avez d'ailleurs
à bridgestone comme ailleurs comme à
auchan comme un nokia comme dans toutes
ses entreprises qui licencient
aujourd'hui vous savez que la décision
est prise par des gens que les salariés
eux mêmes ne voit pas c'est ça le
capitalisme financiarisé et en ferme et
on ré ouvre ici et on joue avec le
dumping social c'est à dire le fameux
prétendu coût du travail mais le travail
n'est pas un coup le travail c'est ce
qui permet de produire de la richesse
donc on a inversé voyez-vous les normes
et quelque part on n'est plus capable de
se protéger et d'avoir une vision pour
que la production correspondent aux
besoins
c'est aussi ça le défi contemporain
terre qu'on arrive à produire des choses
dont on a besoin or là on produit des
choses dont on n'a pas besoin est de
plus en plus comme vous pouvez le
remarquer en créant des besoins on l'a
vu avec eux avec la 5g 1 qui pose toute
une série de problèmes de cette nature
je crois vraiment c'est de se demander
est ce que cette nouvelle technologie
doit être la priorité est ce que on
continue à permettre le développement
d'entreprises dans sur lesquelles on n'a
pas de maîtrise française puisque ce
sont les chinois ou les américains qui
vont développer sa technologie donc
c'est des questions géostratégiques
c'est des questions évidemment d'emploi
etc des caisses et ce sont aussi des
questions environnementales et qui
concerne le développement des
territoires
excusez moi je parle beaucoup des
territoires parce que vous savez que on
a vraiment un problème aujourd'hui vous
avez des lieux totalement désertés des
grandes entreprises ou des moyennes
entreprises est qui et qui sont en train
de sombrer dans la pauvreté dans la
misère et comme en plus les services
publics
s'en vont voyez bien qu'on touche à des
choses qui sont qui sont terribles pour
la vie des gens et slogans déjà les
jaunes massé aussi nicher là d'un grand
débat justement emmanuel macron a tenté
de réimplanter les services publics on
voit une réorganisation de services des
impôts notamment dans les gares et war
ça fonctionne pas pardonnez moi c'est
une plaisanterie
la macro ni n'a qu'une obsession c'est
de diminuer partout l'emprise des
services publics parce que la réduction
des dépenses publiques me croyez que
c'est quoi c'est moins d'argent pour
tous moins d'argent pour les hôpitaux
moins d'argent pour l'école moins
d'argent pour la justice c'est ça qui se
passe moins d'argent pour la recherche
puisque aujourd'hui on entame le débat
sur la loi recherche à l'assemblée
nationale sa veut dire que quand jean
castex à l'assemblée nationale par les
territoires des territoires pour vous ce
sont des paroles et mais je ne sais pas
de quoi ils parlent
je ne comprends pas c'est ce sont des
mots parce qu'il a bien vu qu'il y avait
encore une fois le gilet jaune qui a mis
en lumière justement c'est cette façon
de développer les territoires c'est à
dire de faire un voeu qui concentre à
certains endroits les richesses et qui a
d'autres endroits laisse totalement
désert la possibilité même de ce que je
peux appeler le droit à la ville le
droit à la ville ça veut dire d'être
dans un endroit partout en france où on
peut avoir accès justement à des
hôpitaux de proximité à des commerces de
proximité parce que vous savez que il ya
tout cela qui osa je vais dire renault
air france ils ont une 12 milliards de
prêts 12 milliards de prêts de l'état et
on y va on donne on donne on donne et
qu'est-ce qui prévoit douze mille
suppressions d'emplois bon faut quand
même qu'on s'entende c'est quand même
pas possible c'est quand même pas
possible de vivre comme ça et en même
temps moi le la petite boutique qui est
en bas de ma permanence et qui vend des
chaussures et des vêtements dont on a
bien besoin parce que à villepinte voyez
vous on est dans le nord de la seine
saint denis ya pas beaucoup de commerces
de proximité va mettre la clé sous la
porte parce que les prêts données par
l'êta il ne fonctionne que pour la
partie des petites et des toutes petites
et moyennes entreprises qui sont
finalement déjà à flot donc si vous
étiez si vous étiez limite avant le
confinement ne croyez pas que vous allez
bénéficier du soutien de l'état
en revanche des grands groupes eux vont
être sauvés et en même temps qu'ils sont
entre guillemets sauver en profite pour
m mettre la clé sous la porte de
certaines entreprises ou pour en tout
cas se séparer de salariés
le sommet c'est quand même la famille
mulliez zahlé cochant vous avez vu quand
même que auchan qui a profité elle en
revanche du confinement puisqu'on est
allé davantage dans les hypermarchés
que fait la famille mulliez elle rachète
alinéa qui était dans son dans son giron
et en profite d'une certaine manière
pour éponger les dettes et faire un plan
social et se séparer de salariés c'est
comme une formidable ce système et ce
système c'est quoi c'est un système qui
a été mis en place par des lois par des
choix politiques de gouvernement
successifs successives ça date pas d'il
ya trois ans mais ça a été accélérée
depuis trois ans et ce sont des
décennies de politiques néolibérales
bien appuyé par l'union européenne qui
montre aujourd'hui toutes leurs tout
leur vacuité enfin leur non seulement
leur vacuité mais leur leur dimension
tragique parce que là on arrive dans le
tragique
les plans sociaux j'en ai des listes
lavoyer general electric chez tous les
mettre à faire des listes comme les
gestes de s'allonger et ça reste partagé
allongée et l'état et l'état essaie de
plus ya deux mots c'est une espèce
d'inflation voyez-vous de la
communication mais oui on est là on
vient on se déplace et moi y'a de
capacité de l'état à agir et en fait ce
dont on a besoin aujourd'hui c'est de
faire en sorte que la puissance publique
retrouve sa capacité d'agir et que on ne
laisse pas sur le bord de la route
tous ces salariés qui travaillent et qui
produisent des choses qui peuvent être
utiles pour le pays parce que ça les
bases utile pour le pays
on accompagne les reconversions mais ça
l'état n'est pas stratège et ne s'est
pas organisé on va parler de cette crise
sanitaire et des nouvelles mesures
territorialisée qui ont été annoncés
hier à lyon à toulouse et dans le même
temps aujourd'hui un allègement du
protocole dans les écoles un élève
considérer positive ses camarades
pourront continuer à revenir en classe
désormais il faudra trois cas positifs
pour fermer une classe est ce que c'est
une décision opportune cet allégement du
protocole dans les écoles je pense que
celui ci
me paraît logique voilà je n'ai pas
toutes les informations mais de ce que
je peux lire et comprendre
il me semble raisonnable d'agir comme ça
dans l'école parce que les enfants on la
prend au fur et à mesure ne sont pas
très contagieux et ne développe pas de
façon grave la maladie quand il quand
ils ont après faut protéger les
enseignants ça c'est clair
ces deux bassins les enfants à l'école
vous venez d'un rang des départements ou
à la rentrée il manquait aux 4000
enfance avec ses classes
vous savez que ce chiffre est faux alors
elle va me permettez moi d'en profiter
permettez-moi donc puisque vous me posez
la question shoji à l'évasion et je suis
assez en colère sur ce sujet allez-y
c'est une information qui a été donné
par le recteur de l'académie au moment
de la rentrée devant les parlementaires
voilà la presse a largement repris et il
y aurait eu un espèce de micro climat en
seine-saint-denis bien sûr parce qu'en
seine saint denis
les parents ne voient là ne serait pas
suffisamment républicain et aurait
renoncé à mettre leurs enfants à l'école
il se trouve que ce chiffre est faux
voilà donc nous contenter de gym du
recteur et c'est pas que je le connais
c'est eux
mais vous qui nous ont dit qu'ils
étaient faux et c'est ce que j'ai pu
dans les jours suivants observé c'est là
que je les ai vus à fait le cas d'amy
qui vous ai dit que c'était faux bien
sûr à sevran à villepin moi je prends je
prends les villes de la circonscription
que je représente donc immédiatement je
me retourne vers sevran vers trembler
les maires avec noël je travaille et il
ne ne constate pas ils ne constatent pas
cela donc et vous avez le rêve un
pointage pour savoir à peu près combien
écoutez vous rendez compte
quand je suis sortie de la réunion j'ai
été abasourdi j'étais abasourdi commence
comment se fait-il et nulle part
ailleurs en france on ne constate un tel
décrochage leur qui fut un des cars
décrochage physique concret donc moi
j'étais abasourdi or il se trouve que
ces chiffres étaient basés sur une
mauvaise estime assauts estimations du
rectorat rectorat qui d'ailleurs à sa
rentrée était totalement pu t il manquer
dans les postes de direction un certain
nombre de
deux cadres qui ont été mutés qui
n'étaient pas remplacés
non mais c'est aussi ça la réelle mail
en seine saint denis puis on attend
d'eux correctement c'est pour ça que je
n'ai pas fait à ce jour de communiquer
pour en parler j'attendais que le
recteur le fasse il m'a promis de faire
un rectificatif précis pointé mais vous
croyez quand il y aura le rectificatif
on va avoir tout ce qu'on a eu dans la
presse et dans les médias pour nous dire
la réalité en seine-saint-denis non il
reste une trace qui est une strass de
stigmatisation et je dis faisons très
attention à la façon dont on regarde
notre département est en réalité moi ce
que je constate c'est que les parents
sont très attachés à l'école est très
inquiet de la façon dont l'école se voit
là ne tourne pas aussi rond quelle
qu'elles le devraient et c'est une
inquiétude véritablement des parents
donc puisque vous me posez la question
vous faites leur je rectifie mais je
n'ai pas le chiffre précis en
l'occurrence et nous la faible on est
bien nous sommes des parents avec leurs
activités locatives
autant vous dire je suis assez en colère
de la stigmatisation qui a pu être rendu
tard je vais départ mélenchon a dit que
le gouvernement a dénoncé une
préparation du gouvernement face à la
deuxième vague de contamination
j'ai envie de vous demander qu'est ce
que la france insoumise aurait fait au
pouvoir pour préparer cette seconde
vague alors d'abord comme pour la
première
tout l'enjeu c'est d'être capable
d'organiser d'anticiper on l'a vu avec
les masques voilà c'est même une
anticipation antérieure puisque quand on
a détruit les masques séquences et qu'on
est tellement dans le temps court et
dans la réduction des budgets publics on
n'est même plus capable de prévoir que
il peut y avoir une crise sanitaire
c'est pareil pour le nombre de lits en
réanimation si vous faites
un nombre de lits qui correspond à ce
qui se passe en temps normal vous êtes
incapable on a un nombre de masques se
faire face à une crise nationale ans et
les tester après la crise des masques
pendant la première phase maintenant
nous avons le crash sur les tests sept
jours pour avoir un résultat dès que à
n'en plus finir
le servathon pas dé témoigner achevée
autour de nous de visiblement
d'organisation d'organisation parce que
par exemple saleh que les vétérinaires
pourrait faire ce type de test bon bah
c'est pas organiser tout et tout et tout
et à vau l'eau
donc c'est préoccupant c'est très
préoccupant parce que on se demande si
on va pas vous avoir une deuxième un
deuxième confinement haut-rhin deuxième
confinement aurait des conséquences
sociales économiques psychologiques
aussi très importante donc il faut
espérer
mais l'espoir ne suffit pas il faudrait
avoir un gouvernement voit que sa vie
soit capable d'être d'être sérieux dans
la gestion des choses et moi je suis
assez atterré en fait un de voir à quel
point ce gouvernement ne s'est pas
finalement organiser les choses et ça a
été vrai pendant le confinement et c'est
vrai aujourd'hui notamment avec les
tests ou aussi les masques gratuits que
nous avions demandé je m'en vais mais
quand je vois à chaque fois que je vais
acheter moi même des masques en
pharmacie le prix des masques je me dis
comment voulez vous que les gens se
protègent le correctement de cesser
c'est pas possible je pensais pas
possible tu re sujet clémentine autain
c'est la 5g un qui fait débat en ce
moment et hier à votre place on avait
cédric ou le secrétaire d'état à la
transition numérique qui nous a dit non
à un moratoire
on va discuter avec les élus non ne
changera pas notre calendrier il y aura
un déploiement de la 5g vous attendiez
autre chose alors j'ai posé la question
au gouvernement la semaine dernière
c'est cédric au qui m'a répondu 'oui' ou
plutôt pas répondu puisque j'ai posé
trois arguments pour qu'on prenne le
temps sur la 5g qu'on prenne le temps de
réfléchir
c'est normal d'avoir un débat
démocratique sur ce sujet premier
premier point c'est bien sûr la question
environnementale
ce à un coût environnemental il ne m'a
pas répondu sur ce point questions
géostratégiques
je l'aï dit tout à l'heure on développe
une technologie qui va être utilisé par
les chinois et les américains à mort bon
ça se réfléchit de savoir si on fait
comme ça et enfin vous savez qu'en
france vous avez les gens qui n'ont pas
accès à la 4g ni même à la 3g et que la
fibre est très difficile à obtenir pour
deux foyers donc est-ce que la priorité
c'est pas décidé d'investir de telle
sorte que déjà le maillage soit le plus
il nous dit que ça changera rien mais
c'est faux avec le calendrier sera tenu
sur la fibre bon sur la fibre
effectivement on peut dire c'est autre
chose sur la kadji non le rapport entre
la 4g la 5g vous savez c'est l'histoire
de deux voix ces techniques mais il n'y
a pas pas de lien il n'y a pas pas de
bien et il ne m'a répondu que sur une
question que je ne lui avait pas posé
que la question sanitaire savoir est ce
que les ondes c'est dangereux ce n'est
pas dangereux
il semble que ce ne soit pas dangereux
il faut toujours vérifier mais voilà
mais il ne m'a répondu sur aucun des
voix des trois autres points que je lui
ai posé d'ailleurs vous avez vu que rfi
rue vous avez vu guy hier soir au bureau
politique de la république en marche
il s'est fait tacler par un de ses
collègues qui lui a dit que l'espérer
que sa prise de parole soit plus
brillante que sa réponse sur la 5g sur
le fait qu'il refuse un moratoire
rapidement à je pense que c'est une
faute
c'est une faute sur le plan démocratique
vous savez que la la convention
citoyenne qu'a mise en place emmanuel
macron pour dire d'ailleurs ils en
parlent encore et disant on va demander
à la convention citoyenne à quoi ça sert
de demander à la config convention
citoyenne c'est quand elle dans donne un
résultat c'est à dire sur la 5g elle
veut le moratoire on lui dit bah non
merci
circulez ya rien à voir c'est un vrai
problème démocratique un dernier mot de
politique pure clémentine autain pour
terminer les verts ont rencontré
plusieurs victoires lors des élections
municipales
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il serait légitime
amener un peu la coalition de la gauche
aux élections présidentielles où en sont
vos discussions et comment vous voyez ce
organiser les choses en vue de 2011 moi
il me semble qu'au sein des gauche et
des écologistes aujourd'hui personne ne
peut prétendre à l'hégémonie
c'est-à-dire à être en tête a dominé
je ne crois pas vous regardez les
résultats aux différentes élections
on n'est plus du tout dans le temps on
avait par exemple à parti socialiste
dominant à gauche de façon extrêmement
forte aux quelque part vous aviez des
aiguillons qui venaient ensuite
permettre ou non une coalition on en
n'est plus du tout là je crois donc il
faut maintenant travailler sur le fond
parce que avant de savoir qui peut
emmener il faudrait déjà savoir on est
où
et ce travail là n'est pas encore mené à
son terme
on est en train de se parler on l'a vu
aux universités d'été des uns et des
autres on a vu eric piolle accueillis à
la france à son analyse moi j'étais
europe ecologie les verts enfin si vous
voulez ça circule on se parle et il le
faut il faut aussi affronter les
questions qui fâchent parce que c'est en
affrontant les questions qui fâchent que
nous pouvons imaginer à sauver des
solutions la question qui est il le faut
sur l'union européenne s'est elle fâche
en tout cas nous n'avons pas les mêmes
forcément les mêmes cultures je pensais
l'union européenne je pense à des enjeux
sur la république il y en a d'autres
quand même sur la 5g voyez sur la 5g et
d'autres débats qui compte concerne
l'écologie et la façon dont l impact ce
qu'on appelle la tradition du mouvement
ouvrier et il ya un nouveau tout qui se
cherche
moi je pense qu'on va le trouver je
pense qu'on va le trouver mais on ne
peut le trouver qu'à la condition que
personne dise c'est derrière moi si
c'est quand il y en a eu quelques uns
réside une des forces une des
sensibilités dit allez hop tout le monde
derrière moi et je vais être hégémonique
et vous allez marcher au pas ça ne
fonctionne quand vous entendez le maire
de bordeaux celui de lyon faire les
déclarations qu'ils ont fait la semaine
dernière
est ce que vous dites il va y avoir
problèmes et voir quelles lesquels vais
penser à qu'elle n'éclate en sapin de
noël par exemple à bordeaux
non mais on va quand même mais ça le
tour de france
oui le même camion enfin vous voyez bien
la crise s'est un peu crispé mais enfin
vous voyez bien que si on compense
projet politique on est autour gouverner
la france je vous assure ça tient pas
sympa de noël vraiment vraiment ce sera
le monde l'a bien merci beaucoup merci
clémentine autain d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin